after the death of Supreme Court Justice
Antonin Scalia here are four things you
need to know about what comes next first
the court is now ideologically split
there are four liberals three
conservatives and one swing vote so what
happens when the court splits for four
well the lower court's ruling is upheld
and most of the US appeals courts swing
liberal having been appointed by
Democratic presidents but until Scalia's
replacement is found what's going to
happen for the current cases split at
4-4 well it's likely a liberal win on a
case dealing with labor unions and
another on legislative redistricting but
it's probably a conservative win on the
case of abortion clinic restrictions in
Texas and the case that challenged
President Obama's executive action on
immigration second the hunt is on for
the ninth Justice and it's gonna be ugly
Senate Republicans do not want the bench
to swing liberal for the first time in
decades they say the seat should remain
empty until the next president is in
office 11 months from now but for the
last 12 Supreme Court nominees it only
took an average of two months from
nomination to confirmation or rejection
but because Republicans control the
Senate and therefore the confirmation
process they might just get their way
and of course the presidential election
just got way more interesting every
candidate will surely use the empty seat
as an example of how important the
president's role is Democrats will harp
on protecting abortion rights and
Republicans on the Second Amendment but
several senators are also up for
reelection and how they act in this
nomination process could affect how they
fare with their voters in November so
all this is likely to galvanize a lot
more people to get out and vote
and finally there are other old justices
on the bench too we could find ourselves
in the same position in no time so what
will happen to Scalia's seat and what do
you think the Supreme Court will look
like in a year's time